lasers are everywhere in doctors
surgeries your DVD player even in the
club but before lasers came mazes light
lasers but using microwaves instead of
light based on an effect predicted by
Einstein mazes were invented in the
1950s but scientists only ever managed
to make them either it's super cold
temperatures or high vacuum they did
find some uses like amplifying faith
signals from deep space but they were
soon eclipsed by the much more practical
laser well now scientists have found a
new way to generate mazes at room
temperature and they did it with
diamonds I went to the London Center for
nanotechnology to find out more i'm
jonathan reece i'm a research fellow at
Imperial College London and I've been
working on room-temperature mazes at the
past eight years recently we managed to
demonstrate their continuous room
temperature laser like this opponent
before getting to that though John took
me through how mazes and lasers work the
maser acronym on the laser acronym both
stand for either microwave or light
amplification by stimulated emission of
radiation in order to get stimulated
emission what you need is a population
of electrons where you have two energy
levels and there are more electrons in a
higher energy level than the lower
energy level this putting electrons into
a higher state is called a population
inversion if you can make one of those
then the maser fund can begin an
incoming photon causes one of the
electrons to drop down to a lower energy
level when it does that it emits a
photon and not just any Photon one
that's identical to the photon that just
zoomed by these then trigger more
electrons to drop releasing more photons
in a chain reaction that scientists call
stimulated emission it's a sort of
exponential photocopier for photons
and if the photons are in the microwave
part of the spectrum boom
you get a maser so it was possible to
make the population inversion in in
rubies which they used for mazes but the
the population didn't last very long so
it only lasted for a fraction of a
billionth of a second and so they had to
cool it down to cryogenic temperatures
to make it last for a few millionths of
a second so it was still quite short
that time John and his colleagues needed
to find a material that could sustain a
population inversion at room
temperatures they had some success with
an organic polymer but that could only
generate a pulsed laser to make a
continuous version they turned to
diamonds so you can see actually this is
the core of the Mesa and then inside you
can see the diamond English and release
and within the diamond there are many
color centers in diamonds and envy
Center is one of the most extensively
researched color Center in the diamond
NV centers on nitrogen vacancies are
defects in the diamond structure which
also make it pink where carbon atoms are
knocked out electrons sit in the gaps
the electrons can exist at levels that
are separated by the right amount of
energy to emit microwaves and the
diamonds stable structure keeps a
population inversion even at room
temperature as well as the diamond
there's a sapphire resonator which acts
like a mirror to help intensify the
microwaves the maser produces and
everything is kept in a copper housing
called a cavity so basically this mason
assembly comprising the cavity
disappearing resonator and amazingly
miss a medium the diamond will go in
between the poles of the magnet across
the magnet and then what we do actually
we shine a green laser and when the
laser hits the NV centers the diamond
glows a rich pink that's actually just a
by-product of a much more important
process putting the electrons into their
higher energy state when this is
combined with a precisely calibrated
magnetic field you get that crucial
population inversion
then add the sapphire resonator and the
copper housing and out pops a maser well
I thought we first got involved with the
diamond mite did quite a bit theory I'm
generally Theory Laird so I don't want
to waste my time doing an experiment
that I know well it's work and all the
theory pointed towards it working we had
been trying for about a year to kind of
observe this amazing phenomenon and
we've had no kind of positive results
and then we saw this quirky phenomenon
and I knew what that was and I got very
excited so the next day everyone was
there you know all excited actually so
that's a really great day you guessed it
they'd made a maser I had to go for a
walk to calm myself down so yeah it was
really it wasn't any Rika moment but it
was definitely you know we did it there
Mazur is still pretty weak but it's a
proof of principle and the fact that it
uses envy center diamonds is exciting
because these are already being studied
for other applications quantum computing
oven temperature and also what's called
quantum metrology the fact that we we
use them that kind of diamond for our
nasal should hopefully open it a new
branch in the kind of quantum diamond
technology this technique could not only
make for cheaper and more convenient
mazes it might mean mazes end up being
used in loads more places than today but
since this device is new it's hard to
know yet where that will be over the
past half century or so lasers have
cropped up everywhere now the mazes
found a new lease of life who knows
where it could end up
[Music]